before we get started there's a URL
there tinyurl.com Downey 23 goat that
will get you the slides for this talk
and then later on there are some links
that will get you to some notebooks that
contain some code and some additional
resources at the end so I'm Alan Downey
I'm a Staff producer at brilliant
working on online lessons related to
programming and data science before that
I was a professor at Olan College just
outside of Boston which is a new
undergraduate engineering college and I
worked on a number of books related to
programming and data science including a
new book which is called probably
overthinking it which is being released
today this is the official launch day so
happy launch day everybody and what I'm
presenting today is based on chapter
four which is also called extremes
outliers and goats
so to get started I want to show a video
here of the freeze who is the mascot of
the Atlanta Braves and American baseball
team on the freeze Ro a fan gets a head
start and then the freeze tries to catch
him I mean that's a significant Head
Start no Kidd I didn't think he had a
chance but he just this guying speed
this instead of the mascot race I love
it this guy can fly looks like young D
Nelson and then down goes you lose
Sira so what we just saw there is
evidence that fast Runners are much
faster than ordinary runners in a way
that I think we don't always appreciate
but that race between a pretty good
runner and someone who was a competitive
runner in college shows you how much
faster fast Runners really are and it
turns out that we see the same
Phenomenon with chess players who are
much better than average players and
even among the most elite performers
there's often a goat greatest of all
time and in basketball it's Michael
Jordan in tennis it's Serena Williams in
hockey it's Wayne Gretzky and one thing
I want to point out here looking at the
total points scored in a career here is
the difference between number one and
numbers two three and four so two three
and four scored 1,00
188900 points in their careers Wayne
Gretzky scored almost
2900 almost a thousand more points than
the
second second runner up on this list so
that's an example where the greatest of
all time is substantially better even
than other Elite performers and this
happens not just in athletics but in a
lot of fields Chess music programming
I'm going to claim that any field that
requires this kind of talent training
opportunity and persistence we're going
to see these kinds of outliers and I'll
mention Malcolm gladwell's book also
called outliers that raises some of
these
points so I'm going to try to explain
why this is happening and my claim is
that the distribution of these
capabilities does not follow the
gaussian distribution that we have some
intuition for it follows a log normal
distribution that violates those
intuitions in some ways and to ask why
one more time I'm going to suggest two
data generating processes that might
explain why we see these log normal
distributions I'm going to call them
proportional gain and a weakest link
process so I'm going to start with
proportional gain and I'll use as my
example the distributions of height and
weight so this is Robert wadow he was
272 cm tall which is about 60% taller
than average so that's the tallest
person that ever lived is about 60%
taller than average the heaviest person
reliably measured was 653 kg which is
almost 700 time uh percent 700% heavier
than average so about eight times the
average weight that discrepancy suggests
that these distributions of height and
weight are
qualitatively different and I'm going to
show why that might be the case but
first we need some data I'm going to use
the behavioral risk factor surveillance
system which is data collected by the
CDC it includes self-report reported
height and weight of about 200,000 men
and women in the United
States so we're going to look at some
cdfs some cumulative distribution
functions I'm going to assume that
people are familiar with cdfs but just
as a reminder if we plot the PDF the
probability density function of a
gaussian what we see on the left is the
classic bell curve and if we integrate
that or if we add up those cumulative
probabilities we get the cumulative
distribution function on the right which
is going to look like this sigmoid so
that's what we're going to use to
compare the data sets that we're looking
at with these gaussian and log normal
models so here's a first example this is
the distribution of adult height in the
brfss for female and male respondents
and the uh orange and blue curves here
show the distribution of the data and
the gray line that you can just barely
see is a gaussian model what this allows
us to to judge is how well the model
fits the data and we can see that it
fits pretty well with one possible
discrepancy here between male
respondents uh right around 511 or 6
feet and remember that these are
self-reported Heights suggests that we
have a shortage of people who are 5'11
and a slight excess of people who are
six feet
tall but despite discrepancies like that
we could conclude that the distribution
of height looks like a gaussian
distribution as contrasted with the
distribution of weight so these are the
same respondents again male and female
respondents in the
brfss this is weight on a linear scale
and now we can see that those gaussian
models deviate from the data in a number
of places and I've added these black
crosses uh at the top of the
distribution that show the expected
heaviest person in a data set this size
if the distribution is gaussian and we
can see that the heaviest people in the
data set are substantially heavier than
what we would expect if it were
gaussian the flip side if we now take
those weights and put them on a log
scale we see first of all that there are
now gaussian models that fit the data
very well and if we look at those
crosses up in the upper right hand
corner it looks like the heaviest people
are a little bit heavier than we would
expect in a data set this size but not
by as
much so we could conclude that the
distribution of weight is log normal
although I do want to remind us that
what that always means is that the
distribution is well modeled by a
gaussian or a log normal distribution
nothing in the real world ever follows
these mathematically perfect models
perfectly all right so where do these
distributions come
from fundamentally the central limit
theorem is the explanation if you add up
a bunch of random factors the sum
converges to gaussian and mathematically
that is true that is provably true if
all of those factors come from identical
distributions with finite moments they
are uncorrelated with each other you
have an infinite sample size and if the
operation that you're performing is
literally a mathematical addition and
I'm emphasizing these requirements
because in the real world none of those
things are true but we can still get
something that is approximately gaussian
um not necessarily that the
distributions have to be identical just
that you can't have one or a few of them
that are so big that they dominate all
the others so your random factors have
to be about the same size the tail of
that distribution can't go too far off
to the right they can't be too strongly
correlated with each other obviously you
can't have an infinite sample size in
reality it just has to be big enough and
you don't have to literally do addition
it just has to be mostly addition like
so heuristically we can say that when
we're adding things up they often
converge to something that is at least
approximately
gaussian and I want to invoke the
central limit corollary or at least
that's what I'm calling it which is that
if you multiply a bunch of random
factors together their product tends to
be log normal and one way to see why
that's happening is that when we are
multiplying those factors we are also
adding their logarithms so if Y is the
product of X1 X2 X3 then the log of Y
will be the sum of the log of X1 the log
of X2 the log of
x3 so that suggests a model of why adult
weight might have a log normal
distribution I'm going to run a
simulation where I start with a random
birth weight
and then simulate the life of a person
who at each time step gains or loses
some percentage of their current weight
so we have to start with birth weights
and for that I got data from the
national survey of family growth and fit
a gaussian model to the birth weights of
the male and female babies in the data
set and they look pretty darn gaussian
so our weights at Birth follow a
gaussian distribution but if we simulate
this process where each year you don't
gain one or two pounds you gain or lose
a percentage of your current weight if
you do that then what you get are
simulated weights that look very much
like the data so here I've got the data
again with the orange and blue curves
the gray lines now are coming from
simulations where again I start with a
gaussian and then add add or lose a
percentage of current weight during each
time step and the result converges to a
log normal distribution which might
explain why we are born gaussian and we
grow to be log
normal so that's the first mechanism
proportional gain and that might explain
the distribution of adult weight but
it's not clear how that explains running
speed or chests or these other
uh
attributes I'm going to start with
running and I'm going to grab some data
this is a 10K Road Race that I ran some
number of years ago turned out to be my
personal best time of 42 minutes 44
seconds so I just wanted to get that in
there but if we look at the other 500
people who ran this race and we plot the
distribution of their speeds on a log
scale it looks very much like a log
normal distribution so why should
running speed follow a log normal
distribution my theory is that everyone
has a speed limit no matter how hard you
train at some point you will converge to
your speed limit and you probably won't
get faster than that and your speed
limit is determined by many factors that
interact
multiplicatively so there are probably
physical factors like height and weight
and muscle and aerobic capacity there
are probably py ological and
circumstantial factors like whether you
have the opportunity to train and the
passion to do it and the competitiveness
to reach the elite level and I'm going
to suggest that in order to be an elite
worldclass Runner you need all of these
things you need A and B and C if any of
them are bad that will be your limiting
factor you will not be an elite Runner
and that and operation is analogous with
continuous factors with multiplication
so this is very much like we're taking
all those factors and multiplying them
together and if we do that we only need
about five factors if you sample five
factors from a gaussian and multiply
them together you can get a distribution
that looks very much like the
distribution of running speeds that we
saw now there are some parameters there
that you tune in order to make the
simulation fit the data but the shape of
these distributions is very
similar so proportional gain might
explain the distribution of adult weight
and this process the weakest link
process that you are only as fast a
runner as the factor that is the most
rate limiting factor for you if that
weakest link explains running speeds
then the question is what about other
things like musical performance and
chess per chess ability and things like
that
so I got one more data set which is Elo
ratings from about six million players
on chess.com and ELO ratings are on a
kind of arbitrary scale so there's a
free parameter here to slide this
distribution left and right but with a
certain set of parameters the
distribution of these ELO ratings on a
log scale is looking very much again
like a log normal
distribution so is that proportional
gain is that because of this weakest
link process I'm going to suggest it
could be a combination of both which is
as you learn to do almost anything you
gain metacognition you learn how to
learn and you get exposed to better
teachers and better opponents you have
richer opportunities to learn so there's
some proportional gain but also limiting
factors if you lack an aptitude for that
activity or if you don't have the
opportunity and resources to pursue it
or if you don't have the passion and
persistence to keep at it if you lack
any of those things you will not reach
world class so it could also be a
weakest link kind of process but the
result of all of this I propose is that
Talent is gaussian and lifelong
achievement tends to be log
normal and that might explain this goat
phenomenon the fact that the greatest
tends to be an outlier even among
outliers which we can see if we simulate
say 10,000 or 100,000 people from a
gaussian and a log normal distribution
and I've tuned them to have the same
mean and variance so the difference
between them is just the nature of the
distribution and we look at how far
apart the top three performers are
what we see in the orange curve here
those orange crosses at the top those
are the top three people in a sample of
100,000 and they are clustered pretty
close together because the tail of the
gaussian distribution just doesn't
extend very far off to the right as
contrasted with the log normal
distribution that does have this very
long tail and as a result the top three
performers are pretty substant anally
different from each other and the top
rated chess player there for example
would probably beat the number two
player about nine times out of
10 so the gaussian distribution has this
short tail which means that outliers are
not very far apart the log normal has
this long tail where the greatest of all
time can be much better than someone who
is merely
ilite now I want to talk a little bit
about the methodology here because I've
been asserting that this thing looks
like it's gaussian and that thing looks
like it's log normal I want to explain
where that's coming from because for
some of these measurements one of them
is clearly better than the other but
there are some others where that's not
the case so let's look a little bit more
closely I'm going to use one more data
set which is the anthropometric survey
of US Army Personnel it includes 93
physical measurements like height weight
and arm length from about 40,000 uh
4,000 male and about 2,000 female
members of the US armed forces and we
can go looking through those
measurements to find which ones are best
modeled by a gaussian or a log normal
this is the example that turns out to be
uh the best gaussian fit and the less
good log normal fit male elbow rest
height uh doesn't matter very much what
the measurement is but you can see here
that the gray area that shows the gap
between the model and the data is almost
invisible on the left and somewhat
substantial on the right suggesting that
the gaussian model is better for this
particular
measurement for a weight as we've
already seen the log normal distribution
is substantially better there's almost
no visible gray area on the right
there's a substantial gap on the left
between the best gaussian model and the
data there are other cases like height
where it turns out that both models are
actually really good so I said earlier
that height is well modeled by a
gaussian but it turns out that it is
also just as well modeled by a log
normal
distribution and finally there are a few
measurements like ear protrusion how far
your ears sticks out from the side of
your head that seem to be neither
gaussian nor log normal neither model
fits the data very
well so I want to say where these
parameters come from because how we fit
the model to the data is going to affect
our our our conclusion here and how we
then compare the models to see which one
is better in general when we're
estimating parameters there are a few
different methods uh the method of
moments is to find
the model that has the same mean
variance or other moment based
statistics as the data maximum
likelihood methods which would choose
the model that has the highest
likelihood of producing the data and
percentile matching which is kind of
what we've been doing visually by
comparing
cdfs and then to decide which model is
better we can compare cdfs we could also
uh make a QQ plot which is a similar way
of comparing a distribution to a model
there are likelihood based methods uh
like information criteria and then other
statistics that are used to evaluate the
goodness of fit between a model and the
data I'm going to suggest that because
the thing we care about here is which
model best captures the shape of the
distribution that the right metric to
use and the right way to fit the
parameters is to minimize the area
between the curves the area between the
data and the model and then use that
area to decide which model has better
captured the shape of the
distribution so this is the point where
you might want to uh look at the
notebooks and see the details of what
I'm doing again this the URL here tiny
url.com dowy 23 goat will get you these
slides and from there you can get these
links the chapter 4 notebook is
everything that was in chapter 4 of
probably overthinking it and then the
methods notebook is what I'm talking
about right now which is the comparison
between the log normal and gaussian
models so a little bit of code to show
you how this works the way I'm going to
compute these areas is first by
Computing equally spaced quantiles uh
over the range between the first and
99th percentile of the distribution so
here I'm going to start with a series
that's my data set I'm going to compute
the first and 99th percentiles and then
use Lin space to compute equally spaced
points in that range which you can see
in the figure on the right as those
vertical
lines next I'm going to take that series
of data and compute an empirical CDF
which is the blue curve I'm using a
package here called empirical dist which
is a library that I wrote that I've used
for several of my books and it provides
this CDF object that represents a
cumulative distribution function and you
can call it like a function with
parenthesis in order to evaluate it at
each of these quantiles so again that's
what the vertical lines in the figure
represent that the CDF evaluated at a
range of
quantiles to evaluate the model I'm
going to use ci. stats which provides a
norm object that represents a gaussian
distribution and it provides this
function CDF which evaluates the
analytic distribution of of a gaussian
and what this error function does is it
evaluates the normal distribution the
model at the set of quantiles and then
the CDF of the data at the same set of
quantiles and computes the differences
between them and the average of those
differences is proportional to the area
between these two curves so on the right
hand side I've deliberately chosen a bad
model so that we can see the space
between them and that's what that looks
like finally to minimize the area
between the two curves I'm using least
squares from ci. optimize and I'm using
it with the loss function soft one which
approximates the mean absolute error
it's not exactly the same but mostly
what I'm doing here is minimizing the
area and if we do that for both of the
models and then make a scatter plot of
that area between the curves here's what
we see which is in the lower left cases
where both models are good in the upper
right the cases where both models are
bad the lower right means that the log
normal model is better and the upper
left means that the gaussian model is
better and often both of them are good
but when either of them is good the log
normal model is almost always as good or
better and then occasionally they're
both
bad we see similar results with other
kinds of measurements so this is from
blood test results like hemoglobin and
white blood cell counts in general the
log normal model is
better which contradicts the
conventional wisdom usually we think of
the gaussian distribution as being
ubiquitous it's the default it's we
assume it's gaussian until proven
otherwise and the log normal
distribution is a bit more exotic you
might not see it in an introductory
stats class I'm going to suggest that we
subvert this gaussian hegemony and start
thinking of the log normal model as
maybe being more pervasive than we give
it credit for so let me summarize I
think that there are these two
mechanisms proportional gain and weakest
link that might explain why log normal
distributions are common and that might
explain why Elite performers are
outliers among outliers and why the goat
is the greatest of all
time
if you went to the slides you'll see
some suggestions for further reading I
mentioned Malcolm gladwell's book I'll
also mention Oliver Raiders book which
features Marian Tinsley who was the
greatest player of checkers also known
as drafts uh he was possibly the
greatest of all greatest of all times um
I'll also point you to this paper that
suggests this idea that many of the
things that we think of as gaussian
might actually be better modeled as log
normal and finally I'll suggest probably
overthinking it this is from chapter
four and there are uh 11 more chapters
that I think are just as interesting if
you'd like to to take a look at
that also in the slides I've mentioned
some previous talks that I've given
about other chapters in the book but
that's really just there so that you
have those links for later use I will
stop there so that we have a couple of
minutes for questions and here are a few
different ways that you can get in touch
with me so thank you great Alan thanks
so much um so yes we do have uh one
question in the Q&A which I will show
here um question what processes would
create distributions which are even more
heavy tailed compared to log normal
distributions yeah good question so um
there are longer tail distributions
including the student T distribution
when it's on a log scale and um
especially the power law distribution
the Paro
distributions the same proportional gain
model that I described here with a
little bit of tweaking often yields very
longtailed distributions so one of the
ways to get power law distributions is
the rich get richer phenomenon um and in
fact I will mention that chapter seven
of probably overthinking talks about
these these
mechanisms the other one that I'll
mention is the student te distribution
and um on a on a long scale where that
comes from is a mixture of gaussians
that have a range of different variances
so you if you stack a bunch of gaussians
on top of each other the high variance
contribution to that mixture tends to
pull that tail out into the extremes
awesome thanks so much um so there are a
couple of comments that I'll just if see
if there's something here that um uh
Mustafa just made a comment during your
talk uh but the data sets from the Army
is biased anyways because there's a
height link for so height limit for
soldiers isn't there does that uh any
thoughts yeah no that's a good point
yeah so the the nice thing about that
data set is that there are 93 different
measurements of you know height and and
weight but also you know arm length and
Ankle width and all sorts of funny
things so it's a useful data set because
of the richness but it is not a
representative sample of of the US and
particularly in the extremes so that's
where I think the other data set the uh
brfss is useful it's a much larger data
set it's about 400,000 people and it is
very deliberately designed to be
representative of the US population